[Music]
hi everyone my name is mcclain Wilkinson
I am one of the cofounders of a company
called to do ciphers we work on it a nod
of bhakti re-encrypted we've implemented
or several different distributed systems
I'm going to focus on what we've
implemented or talk to any specialized
applications today but we've also
previously a letterbox reproduction or
other distributed systems specifically
do Kafka and celerity stuff but today
I'll be talking about our decentralized
humanitarian system so basically the
problem resolved is we're in a privacy
later for blockchain in decentralized
applications so we give developers a way
to store share and manage private data
on public block chains are more
specifically public park systems like
ipfs and swarm that sit on top of these
public pockets
so for example if you're building a
medical record application let's say on
top of a theorem and you want to store
patient records on ipfs we give you a
way to have this record to be private
confidential encrypted but at the same
time how does the directors still be
shareable with a valid recipient so
let's say a doctor or hospital and we're
in its access to toilet for structure
for anyone that's building and
centralized augmentation to some of the
variation of low-hanging free use cases
is obviously like encrypted and then you
could did decentralize vouchers you
could imagine using the cipher as a
primitive to build a decentralized
Dropbox for example where you need to
encrypt and share say photos with your
friends family or this metal parenthesis
case record your healthcare provider
it's also a very competitive for
building and to end encryption group
chats and this actually isn't just a
challenging problem
it's naturalize context but also of
centralized context namely because
encrypting each message between each
participants in a larger group chat is
the very
it's an expensive operation which is why
telegram you chance my defaulters are
all play text whereas you can use proxy
decryption the easily add and revoke
read and write access to an encrypted
channel you can also use proxy
encryption to build or construct data
changes are in marketplaces where you
have something cryptic content let's say
it's genomics data or video streams and
you only want to give people access to
that property content in exchange for
payments you can combine epoxy addiction
with smart contracts say only allowed
decryption in the event that the
recipient pay in the same IP to the Dean
owners address we kind of compare proxy
encryption or we're doing for the apps
to HTTPS for decentralized applications
so obviously the way we solved the data
integrity of data confidentiality
problems in a centralized context is
with things like TLS and encryption and
transit in place but fundamentally when
you're using these centralized service
providers like Dropbox or box with
Google all the data is getting decrypted
server-side and while it's probably fine
to trust Google Dropbox with your data
it doesn't make any sense at all we
extend this to decentralized context
where you could be storing data on a Mac
yet best known is sitting in Russian or
something in a person's basement y'all
see what I have you don't want to just
sort of throw anything out there
particularly in this it's a bit
sensitive and so what we've done at
these hydrants we've created is combine
two core technologies to create a way to
manage either data effectively creating
centralized keep manager service the two
technologies of use or proxy encryption
and then obviously decentralization
using the theory of watching it's up to
that I'll talk a little bit about what
proxy reading function is and how that
works proximity encryption is
fundamentally just a more scalable form
of traditional public encryption so if
you think of traditional public
encryption is being very good for
one-to-one communication let's say I
have some secret message that I want to
share with one of you the audience I can
encrypt that message with your public
key and then across the network you can
decrypt with your private key works very
well but let's say I need to share that
message with not just one of you but
everyone in this room everyone in this
conference everyone on this block a
couple hundred or thousand people that
starts get very expensive legend could
the message reach we said the
undescended across the network and
become discharged to scale very poorly
and with proxy encryption what I can do
instead is I can encrypt that data
message one time under my own key I can
store that data
you know s3 or idea pastor or swarm and
then I can delegate revoke access so the
name is arbitrarily as many recipients
as I want using something called a
rear-engine key and basically what pox
encryption allows me to do is to
re-encrypt a reeking of transform that
is me into being encrypted for some
recipients and that could happen without
ever exposing the plaintiff data to the
storage layers was it direct ciphertext
a ciphertext transformation and you can
imagine using proxy decryption to build
a centralized key management service you
know in this case we have some you know
owner you have some you know all data
that they want to encrypt and store a
storage layer so what they'll do is
they'll rip the bulk of the data with a
symmetric key that symmetric e with
their public key attach that encrypted
symmetric either the data encrypted data
and store it FS or any storage layer if
they want to delegate access to that
data to some recipients what they could
do is they can take that recipients
public key use that public key along
with their own private key to create
something called B encryption key and
after one of my function so much do you
use the two inputs
another highly inner-city creative
energy there's no way to reverse that
and they'll give that mean completely do
some untrusted proxy and the only thing
the proxy can do with that data is the
re-encrypt they in terms of symmetric
key so it is now encrypted for the
recipients and recipient can use their
own private key to decrypt it and use
that to decrypt the bulk of the data
we've actually taken that a step further
and created a split pea threshold
version of pop super different we call
homeroom and basically it's you know
we'll see you can set some freshmen will
say 30 or 50
I think of wondering if you split it up
into a bunch of shares it set some
threshold number of those shares that
are required in order to reading print
say 30 50 10 or 20 whatever you like
this to normal we issue those shares out
to a network of poxy for those and then
in order to recreate some forum
refreshment number of those nodes with
the resident I'm gonna be sharing even
come together and research
so this basically splits the trust
across many nodes as opposed to one and
if you're using the cypress thing of s
now you don't need to trust a
centralized service privately AWS
apologist and warehouse report vault or
even decipher just a few details on the
threshold algorithms we've created
because I'm wrong basically the key
capsulation scheme so you don't actually
be encrypted the bulk of the data all
that you can for performance reasons
generally generally both of the data
with the symmetric key and they don't do
the reading pressure and all of that
into symmetric key we also have a way to
verify the correctness of the encryption
petrographic Li which is kind of
interesting we have a lot more
documentation our github or at the repo
and then we have a reference
implementation but we
I thought which is also available so we
also have tokenize it's protocol the
reason we do this we need some way to
should be work to the nodes in the
network as well as penalize people to
run nodes so that's done with our toe
even if you want to be good in the new
cypher network give the state it took it
as a form of collateral person purity
deposit we do that we do a couple things
with that why do you we use it to
allocate work so you'll get reinforcing
keys you provide recursion services for
the network in proportion to the amount
of state that you put up and we also use
it as a way to ensure that nodes are
behaving correctly so yeah the malicious
node or a node because a heart isn't
doing its job that the state will get
slashed a few examples of the types of
these cases that we're singing are a big
one is this medical record estate
attorneys case that talks about before
there's a lot of projects that are using
us to create patient controlled than a
402 platform so many blocks over here in
the same Europe we also enable this idea
decentralized and exchanges or david
marketplaces so are a lot of projects
like data erosion protocol that are
aggregating a bunch of different kinds
of data it could be either browsing
history social media data genomics data
they're encrypting that data and then
monetizing it by auctioning it off to
advertisers or researchers initially
decrypting anything change for payment
we've also seen a lot of database and
start to use us as the access control
there so being able to control it Kanak
we have to query some centralized
databases like dissolve all the mountain
elements are this happens in public on
our github and discord if you're
interested in learning more we have a
very detailed technical white paper
which is also available on github or on
our website
again that reference implementation of
Umbro is on github in python 10 my email
is just motivated you suffer
thank you very much I'm gonna take the
first question
Oh God you mentioned a theorem a few
times
Oh watch gene-specific Carter sure so
it's so we are particularly at once
doesn't top of material but sort of a
metaphor the most of your billion yeah
on another platform you still use these
hyper groups have have some way to do
cross chain payments which sort of
doesn't think this that well David soon
also for whatever reason there's nothing
specific about him fearing that these
nice night for work other than having or
contract so for whatever reason needed
to move to another popcorn future we can
just say in the States
my question is about that there's a kind
of culture creator if I create my
concepts and blockchain by itself
that's a I'm using the statement or
balance or those kind of platform so I
mean great to create in my content
it's already love changes already
immutable and I can monetize that so
once you add here is more security to
advance or we may see visibility so we
are a way to control you can again
access the data so it's public data you
know it says a blog post on Steven or
something like that then you probably
don't care everyone the world sees it
but if you want to gate access that data
let's say it's like metal record or
something and you want to control the
key and kick for it access that data you
only want to allow say your health care
provider or it's some piece of content
you want to monetize by selling access
to it you can use us as a way to control
additionally you could allow others to
additionally be permitted exchange for
payment okay other companies wants to
meet those data exchange platform
Danny's permission so you can give some
people permission
different type of mate yeah so you could
have you can combine this with the
system or contract that says only allow
access to this piece of encrypted data
to whoever the highest bidder is or only
allow access if they've you don't paid
access to video stream if they pay like
something my subscription eats your
athletes great teacher
so I'm almost gonna question what kind
of how general are these methods you've
implemented so for example what you're
describing earlier with having
multi-party secure communication sound
like there might have been things like
Sameer secret sharing scheme you got
constant is this a really general
nineteen-year is it
so cific to that use case sure so this
is like a very similar probe this
ability when the reinforcing key is very
similar to the mere secret sharing which
is just splitting a private key so it's
the same concept you're splitting up
this this key the difference here is
we're splitting up three encryption key
versus putting up a private key so it's
actually this case is slightly more
secure because if someone is able to
maliciously get ahold of a sufficient
number of shares to reassemble the key
in the case of Shamir secret sharing
they reassemble the private key which
gives them access to data in this case
they just me he assembled the reaper two
key which only allows them to be able to
do this they also have to do that plus
compromise whatever private key that
that maker think you used is reading
1500 targeting
you